foreign
[Music]
projects are generally tied to an
organization in the resource hierarchy
now situations like Acquisitions or
reorganizations or handoffs from
Partners may require you to migrate
projects from one Google Cloud
organization to another or migrate an
Oculus project
let's face it project migrations can
seem sort of intimidating but I have
good news
Google Cloud resource manager enables
you to migrate projects from one
organization to another with ease let's
get started on our journey with
migrating a project by taking a quick
look at the key steps
first create a migration plan
second assign IAM permissions at the
right levels next configure organization
policies on both the source and
destination organizations then handle
any special cases
finally migrate the projects between
organizations for migrating a project
it's important to evaluate if there will
be any impact to Services running inside
that project
so use cloud asset inventory to create
an overview of resources in use in the
project including IAM policies applied
to them
verify and ensure that the effective
policies at the destination organization
align with your governance objectives
and match what's at the source
check if your project has a customer
managed encrypted key or any Cloud Key
Management Service enabled on it you
need to keep this in mind as it will be
required once you start operating your
project in the destination organization
after migration if you have any preview
features enabled on your project then
ensure that these features are not
private and are allow listed for the
destination organization to allow smooth
functioning of the feature ensure that
you have the relevant IM permissions and
set the required organization policies
so that you can roll back the project
migration If You observe any issues
after migration policy inheritance can
cause unintended effects when you are
migrating a project both in the source
as well as destination organizations you
can mitigate this risk by creating
specific folders to hold only those
projects that you want to export and
import and ensure that the same policies
are applied to both let's assume we have
two organizations called Acme and Bonsai
with the resource hierarchy as shown in
this representation I will now show you
how to move the project titled
development project from the Acme
organization to the Bonsai organization
go to the manage resources page in the
Google Cloud console set up a dedicated
Source folder called export to new
organization set up a dedicated import
folder in the destination organization
on both these folders assign the project
mover role to the person responsible for
migrations
this role will then be inherited by any
projects that are contained within these
folders
to migrate a project between
organizations you must have the
following roles on different entities
project mover role on the Project's
parent resource which could be either a
folder or organization
and project mover role on the
destination resource if it's a folder
project create a role on the destination
resource if it's an organization
project IIM admin role on the project
that you want to migrate additionally
ensure that the user setting the
organization policies has the org policy
admin role on both the source and
destination resources to enable creation
and management of organization policies
next you need to set the appropriate
organization policies on the source and
destination resources to allow export
and import of projects respectively for
this set the policy that includes
allowed export destinations constraint
on the Project's parent resource which
sets up the destination as a valid
location to which the project can be
migrated
similarly set the allowed import sources
constraint on the destination resource
this sets up the source as a valid
location from which the project can be
migrated
note that your environment May consist
of some special cases such as the ones
listed here for which you must follow
additional steps before you can do the
migration
refer to this documentation to learn
about all the special cases and to
follow relevant instructions for your
environment
finally you can migrate the projects
using Google Cloud CLI or apis okay so
we are here at the final step of our
migration Journey
I will now run the move command in the
Google Cloud CLI to migrate our project
development project from organization
Acme to another organization bonsai
and there you have it we have
successfully migrated the project
development project
to learn more about resource manager and
migrating projects between organizations
check out the following documentation
thank you for watching
[Music]